Let's take a closer look at longest prefix match.
So each packet has a destination IP address, which determines
where the package should be forwarded next. And a
router basically looks up a table entry that matches that
address. So for example, a forwarding table might have
a number of prefixes in it. And many of these
prefixes might be overlapping. But when we see an
IP address, it may match. On one or more prefixes
in this table, you simply match that IP address to the entry in the forwarding
table with the longest matching prefix. So the benefits of cider and longest
matching prefix. Our efficiency, since prefix blocks
can be allocated on a much finer
granularity than with classical inter-domain routing, any
opportunity for aggregation if two downstream networks with
more specific or longer prefixes, should be treated
in the same way. By an upstream network,
who might simply aggregate two contiguous shorter prefixes
into one forwarding table entry with a shorter
prefix. For example, a benefit for aggregation might
exist if two downstream networks A and B
each had slash 16 address space allocated to
them. But upstream, all the traffic always cam
through same upstream network, C. If the rest
of the internet only reached A and B.
Via C, then the rest of the internet
need only know about C's address space which might
be 12/8. This might allow the upstream network
to simply aggregate, or not announce these more specific
prefixes, since they're already covered by the less
specific upstream prefix. Now cider had a significant effect
on slowing the growth of the internet routing
tables from 1994 to 1998. So, from 1994
to 1998, we see roughly linear growth in
the number of prefixes in the internet routing
table. Around 2000, fast growth in routing tables
resumed. You can see that growth here once
again started to pick up a significant contributor
to this growth, was a practice called multi-homing.
Multi-homing can actually make it difficult
for upstream providers to aggregate IP
prefixes together, often requiring an upstream
provider to store multiple IP prefixes for
a single autonomous system. Sometimes those
IP prefixes are contiguous and sometimes
they aren't. Let's take a quick look at how multi-homing can stymie aggregation.